and we're live good morning good
afternoon good evening wherever the hell
you are in the world and welcome to C
try SciFi TV and Movie Channel and I'm
sorry we're late it's my fault it's all
my fault he asked me a question and I
went on like a 30-year journey into
filmm yeah I had hair when I asked the
question yes he had I had I had
some but we are joined by Rebecca from
the from the companion and three fry
short I mustn't forget three fry short
yes we're going to be talking Stargate
obvious L I got my star t-shirt on and
everything also we're going to be
talking about the companion and you've
got um a big event coming up next
weekend and obviously we're here with
stormmy bear so hello hello
hello before we get stuck into it and we
will talk about starting stuff but
before we get stuck into it Rebecca do
you want to tell us about um that you're
doing a Christmas special at the week
sure can I just say though that as soon
as you put sort of Christmas special my
brain goes goes to Star Wars
and it's bad places bad
places it goes to bad places
oh it goes to the Star Wars Christmas
Special yeah I mean we kind of when we
came up with the idea of a holiday
special we were like oh that'd be really
funny you know if we did something that
had lots of segments or song or whatever
um and it's there's going to be some of
that but there's not going to be a ton
of it um I've got some fun little actual
holiday segments that are kind of
Stargate um with a Stargate flare to
them but we're also we're going to be
joined by Brad Wright again um and we're
going to be talking all sorts of
Stargate as well um we're going to take
it as an opportunity there were a lot of
questions that got asked in a lot of our
live streams on in the comments that we
couldn't get to for one reason or
another um so we're going to go back and
we're going to do that we're going to do
like a year in review so it should be it
should be a really fun it's going to be
completely wide open you don't have to
be member you don't have to sign up for
the newsletter or anything it's actually
already you can see it on the
companion's YouTube site upcoming live
so um everybody should just come hang
out uh I'm going to be dropping some
recipes next week beforehand for some
Stargate related holiday drinks so if
you want to make your drink and then
come and join um should be a good time
just pred
up
beverages uh yeah so it's the 16th
that's next Saturday and it'll be at 2:
p.m. Eastern which is 11:00 a.m. Pacific
which is 700 p.m. uh across the pond for
you uh over there so uh in England and
other time zones you'll have to figure
it out I'm
sorry sorry not doing that I think it's
5 am in Australia I don't know it's yeah
hey we have oh who is it that keeps
coming on I think it's it's one of the
marks that keeps coming on because will
you please start doing your videos a
little bit earlier I'm in
Australia I'm sorry mate it's hard when
you got a global audience it's hard it's
so rough having a global audience you
know we suffer
greatly 20 closing in on 28,000
subscribers people come on for
Christmas um so if you haven't
subscribed uh but there are links to the
companion YouTube channel which go and
subscribe to because then um even when
you do the companion videos don't you on
the on the on the web page you then
throw shorts and everything on yeah yeah
yeah we're we're getting really dropping
a lot of Clips these days so um and
we're we're trying to keep that going so
you'll get a lot of interesting content
um and you'll get you'll get heads up
for for things coming up like we have
Amanda again uh in January and we've got
some Star Trek things in January as well
so if any Star Trek people out there
we're gonna have two weekends back to
back with uh John Billingsley and
friends so um exciting Arman Shimmer and
his wife are coming on on January 6th so
yeah yeah
um so I've just seen my friend Ralph has
just popped up and I'm I'm going to
ignore his comment so I'm having I'm
he's my nesis and I'm having an argument
with him and um I'm just going to ignore
it I'm not g block you Ralph I don't
care I'm not blocking I didn't block you
before but you were getting abusive so
let's just leave it that anyway um I've
lost my train of thought because of Ral
well no no I just gave my whole
companion Spiel so yeah we're good to do
whatever there are links in the
description for the companion YouTube
channel for the web page and for the
Christmas
so you can all go and put your little
clicks on reminders for the the holiday
special um God you remember that bit
when the W started
singing yeah I'm sorry I'm sorry you're
having those uh those flashbacks but I
promise it's not gonna be like
that she says that now she says that
yeah she says that and then they all
start singing at the end together arm in
arm with
brand um but anyway so I I've and
there'll be a little bit of um there'll
be a little bit of me in there I've just
sent you the clip that I saw it saw it
come through yep um and Brad W has
promised to do us a little shout out so
if he forgets give him a poke
well he's promised to wish us wish the
Sid trackers a merry Christmas for me
sounds like perfect that's fair enough
and I'm gonna clip it and put it on my
channel I got I gotta get something out
of this things yeah yeah of
course
um I've already I I sent one of our
friends to the channel Harris actually
Young American was over at New York com
not La ComiCon last week so we pinned
Jenny sty into the ground and made it a
do one as well so we've got a little
video from Jenny as well so that'll be
love
Jenny and then you've all got to listen
to me singing the 12 days of Stargate
that's our Christmas video nice it's so
bad it's it's awful um there will be a
segment just so you know called the gate
Before Christmas
uh in ours so yeah yeah so I feel you on
that
yeah um yeah uh I actually did one
version and I realized it was so bad it
wasn't funny just bad so I had to do it
again and now it's just so bad it's
funny so um hopefully anyway hope you
people love it so I auto was just
autotune I
auto really help there are notes in
there that aren't notes honestly there's
there's dogs all there going what the
hell anyway though so
2024 we we we thought we said we talk
about starget a little bit and and
Rebecca I really want to talk about some
of the the interviews you've had like
Amanda and and anybody El um but I'd
love to know sort of what your opinions
are on what you think MGM and Amon are
actually doing at the moment
and what do you think do you think 2024
might bring us some good news think you
know I can't tell anymore um honestly at
this
point and i' and and I've at this point
also trying not to get my hopes up
because I feel like we were so close and
it was supposed to happen and then like
other things happened so um and so so
now I'm just wary of thinking whether
it'll happen I would love for it I would
love to get an announcement but um I
don't know I don't think we'll see
anything in 2024 but maybe we will will
get some news in 2024 maybe so
um for it but yeah MJ put out their sort
of development slate I think that's
ended January early February so if that
if it's going to be a series it should
be on that um the only thing I've got
I'm holding on to Jenny St keeps telling
me to stop stressing because I'm just
like I keep hearing rumors and she's say
don't worry it's fine I'm
like
just okay um but um the one thing I
think is like we haven't had an
announcement on Robocop and and we know
that was happening we they haven't had
we haven't even had an announcement on
Legally Blond three and that's the thing
we're most excited
about so um and that hasn't been
announced either
so I don't think we should worry they're
just taking forever yeah I don't know I
there was concern when uh the strikes
started and they they went on for a
really long time I my personal concern
was it could end up killing a lot of
projects that they had totally planned
to do um I don't necessarily
think something like a new Stargate
would would be in that oh we're just
gonna like kill this but you know it it
is a concern for sure you know it
changed a lot like that six months of
everybody being on strike changed a lot
so it's something we've talked about a
lot there a lot of people I was talked
to basically saying in all the studios
one the one go said he's an agent um or
he works for in one of the agencies and
he sort of said you don't want to give
Executives time to sit around doing
nothing they they think and we don't
want them to think they they just want
him to sign checks and like please
please write yeah yeah exactly um but it
was saying that they're all just sat
around and they're just like I the
projects have been well I was talking
about Battle Star Galactica then that
was supposed to and they um signed on to
do a 10 episode run and now they've told
them they're doing a pilot and they're
sort of like uh and app was sort like
but um the studio like yeah and they've
scrapped the 10 episodes and they've
starting again wow and did the same with
um uh Daredevil and a million other
projects we'll never know that they
decid to scrap so it is a worry yeah
yeah for sure um but we were pretty sure
we were getting a movie and if it means
they stop and have a think and do a
series
instead I think most Stargate fans would
be pretty pleased with that to be
honest as as long as you know
everybody's got the concerns the where's
where's Brad we don't have Brad like
what what's happening um is it going to
be a continuation please don't just
reboot the whole thing all those things
you know we're going through all of
those concerns and and worries and and
nervousness and we don't even know what
anything about it at this point
so we even have little bits and and and
and hear little rumors about things but
then it it well it seems to be that the
development process stuff changes so
they seem to be going one way and then
somebody will come up the bright to go
another way Brad has said it before that
they they approached MGM approached him
for a script he he wrote a script and
then it completely changed like they
went a completely different direction so
yeah it changes very rapidly and and
often so the thing is with the Brad
script I I was told ages ago um that
actually Amazon were were one of the
they were actually pushing for that they
were sort of like MGM if you produce
that we know it'll go in MGM Plus in
America but internationally we probably
buy that so Amazon were interested there
but this is when the sort of before the
sale went through um and they were
talking to you know starting to build up
those relationship things so they were
interested then if it's assuming that
that was true sort of thing yeah um then
and it would have gone on sci-fi I think
I think sci-fi were involved as well if
I remember right um
so it's
like we'll do it then right you didn't
spend eight billion dollars just for
James Bond and Legally Blond 3 even
though obviously now that's a good
probably two billion dollars just for
Legally Blond three but um H so
yeah we can but hope I I'm I'm I'm will
be very interested when the MGM slate
comes out yeah for sure it's not on that
I will be like pulling my hair out then
that be I will be stormy by the the time
that
comes but it's all gone quiet again now
but apparently everyone's sort of people
are sping talk to like nothing really
happens now it's like as soon as um sort
of thanksgivings in America everyone's
sort of on autopilot until the new year
apparently yeah and I think there's that
it added having to regroup you know
after the strike too so it's probably a
little worse even than than most years
so Al apparently Amazon have had a
problem with their Studio space they
can't get enough
this was just mental um they've got a
bunch of projects they haven't been able
to restart because they haven't got
Studio space apparently um I I don't
have no idea how that works I mean
somebody's got to get sacked over that
surely right but you know can we start
filming no why
no you know that studio supp I supposed
to rent I forgot but oh
mind what would you prefer though would
you prefer a TV show or a movie or
something else what do you think I would
prefer a TV show and it's it's a I would
like my ideal new Stargate would be uh
it's the same amount of time as pasted
so we're we're in modern we're in
present day um you got General Carter
like heading up SGC so you get to see
that occasionally but you've got you
know new SG teams um that's what I would
like to see I don't know um yeah I was
say my idea for how this should
start for the new
whatever so should start
with get
comfy this might take a
while so the way I think whatever the
new thing is series or you know movie
you know we're probably in the days of
postdisclosure you the world knows start
existence is whatever and it should be
like you know camera moving you know
through a lock and it come a doorway you
hear some rockus behavior in the
background and the camera pans on a sign
that says um middle uh Dr Daniel Jackson
uh Middle Kingdom you know and he's get
reiving his lecture that he started that
he was in the produ in in the middle of
during the first movie you know he's
actually giving giving that with insight
now that it's all public and now he gets
Vindication finally you know that I
think it should start with that lecture
and then he's answering questions you
know he's going through and somebody
says the name of some doctorine and you
know and then he says yeah and he's
still a fraud you know and I think it
should start with his lecture from the
beginning but this time post disclosure
with all the goodies and he's got a
packed house no one 's leaving standing
room only you know
I
like I I I want to see that I'll take
one day I'll take one I'll take one day
uh you know just regular pay you know
scale pay and a writing credit and I'm
good bad Tom but after two years talking
about Stargate if I don't get some sort
of executive producer role I'm gonna be
gutted was
like should at least get a
cut
1% of the of the post um yeah yeah Sarah
said it perfect in the chat Vindication
for
Danel I quite like it actually it is a
good idea um because it it mirrors the
start of the first movie that's what I
like about it so if there is about three
people setting the front of the um the
audience so that be that' be cool um and
with our Michael Shanks up front instead
of uh instead of James speder but I want
James SP to do a I'd love James P to be
like sit in the audience doesn't say
anything we could just see him so
they um I would have loved
it yeah I think it was like was it Brad
talking about how they nearly got Kurt
Russell on
sg1 hey Jack hey Jack I hear I hear that
uh I hear that SP really really hated
being on St being in that in the movie
so um I think it was more because he
just hated the heat wasn't it I think
maybe yeah because they're in the desert
most of it and he just hated it um but I
mean yeah but uh James bade is one of
those people as well from from obvious
I've never met him so but from looking
at reading interviews because I'm a bit
of a sper fan I've loved him and
everything oh yeah he wonderful bossing
legal is still one of my favorite shows
I love that show Denny
Crane um every two years or so I watch
it my I've got my son to watch it really
he's just like this is really good is
the fifth season the last one or can I
watch it some can I watch another season
somewhere else you know M sorry that's
last one ah
God calm down anyway um but um yeah so
he he's like sort of he considers
himself like sort of a proper actor so
he doesn't he finds like he actually
said the um the film he really hated
making was um mannequin he just he
thought yeah that makes sense it's a bit
Yeah but sometimes I can't imagine being
an actor doing sci-fi it must be
ridiculous you know you s to the screen
go Captain raise Shields and you must
feel so silly as a grown adult you know
doing that sort of thing we've been
hit it must be hard but you're an actor
I suppose yeah that's your job you know
um yeah especially if you have like all
the all you have nothing that you can
see that you're having to re you can
react to it's just green screens
everywhere so like that's impressive to
me that you can emote and there's like a
monster in front of you but there isn't
and you you have to like sell it so yeah
I saw Michael Jack Michael Jackson
Michael Shanks in one of the conventions
talking about how um I think it was it
wasn't Thor's hammer it was the second
time they went to that planet and the
Asgard did come Thor's Chariot Thor's
Chariot thank you or what we call on
three fres short Thor's wagon Thor's
wagon um they saying like the four of
them sort of turned around and they were
supposed to look in a as um as Thor's
ship came down and
and they just sort of looked looked at
it went and then turned and then they
looked it back later and oh my God we
look so
stupid because would because we learned
on that day don't underestimate what the
special effects guys can do because they
actually do a good job yeah you just
turn around and go it was like me when I
was at the Grand
Canyon what do we do now
right um that just made me think about
that because stormy you were at the
Grand Canyon this week would you mate oh
oh yeah deep deep in the back well that
was a rough hike that was a rough had a
great time spent three day uh three days
at the Grand Canyon and I'm still
hurting in places I didn't know I hurt
and I burnt the crap out of my
lips burn I thought you they're all
sunburned man you want the gross
closeup if you've never been sunburned
on your lips it's uh Next Level awful
it's next yeah oh I got sunburns on the
bottom of my feet
once rough yeah so painful stupidly I'd
sunbathed but I didn't have anything on
my feet so I did but I got I got lotion
on my back I just didn't think about my
feet um and they blistered it was it was
so painful um I was on a cruise not long
ago right and um they tell you on the
hot days you must wear sandals if you go
out on deck and I just thought I'm only
going there I'm just going there and I'm
coming straight back it won't be too bad
it was bad I ended up like jumping up on
2 a
sun this person next Su what are you
doing
nothing so much pain um and then trying
to like trying to run and not hover as I
trying to run back to the shade um but
yeah oh don't don't ever burn your feet
it was it's bad
um what did track gate say there then
who would actually make the Stargate
public knowledge would it be the nid I
think it just be the military wouldn't
no the president would do it I was
actually genely thinking when Trump was
president that he might announce
it so yeah I think I think it would have
to be I think that they would have to go
public eventually because uh
internationally like all of the you know
the UN everybody like that would have to
you know the US can't keep it for
themselves for forever you know it's not
GNA happen Russia's gonna get mad again
like but we'll try we'll certainly we
will try oh man don't underestimate us
like you Americans would ever uh think
you're better than everybody else and
keep all the toys for ourselves
no um so yeah I I just where do you
think like say I'd love tobea tonight
where do you think Stargate would be now
then for one do you think it'll be an
open you think it'll be known to the
public or we try and keep that because
one of the things I love about Stargate
was that it could be real
you know it could be true because it's
secret and whatever but do we do we
forget that
and
I I
think yeah I think it would probably I
think it would probably have to be uh
known at least more widely than than it
you know super top secret that it is in
in the other in the existing series but
um I don't know that's a good question I
get that it is fun because
oh it could be real I get I totally get
that but I feel like you're at what
almost 30 years at this
point that just I don't know I don't I
don't I don't have an answer but I think
it could make for some interesting on
Earth uh political episodes um if you
did make it public there would be there
would be more conflict probably with
stuff on the on Earth as well so
I think it give us some nice flashback
episodes as well and things like that we
get through the first season or second
season where we see how it happened what
do you think
stormmy I know we've discussed this
before yeah
it's well well let me just start off
with the basic premise here you go you
all sit down the basic you know it's for
me as a fan no matter what I get I'm
going to be happy yeah I mean you know I
am just that kind of an you know and
I've talked a lot about sci-fi
franchises and what's the biggest and
what's the most
pervasive and you know once you get
through Star Wars and Star
Trek Stargate has been there for decades
and hundreds of episodes produced across
many series not en counting all the
comic books and the novelizations and
not and and just you know straight up uh
individual plotline uh novels you start
and so what whatever I even if I got a
new I don't know six series comic book
I'd be thrilling you know so it's I want
a bit more than that a little bit more
than
that seven comic book series seven okay
seven I get an extra one yeah uh and and
a
gra
but I just I I like Brad Wright's answer
to this to be fair we said he actually
gets to a point where it's morally
objectionable that it would still be a
secret and I think about how many
planets have we given aquid reactors to
and we're still burning fossil fuels by
the you know and also eventually
somebody's gonna attack Earth and people
are gonna you know like in that 30y year
time span if it's not the Goa old it's
or the orai it's somebody else
somebody's gonna attack Earth and then
all of a sudden everybody's gonna be
like how do these people know like what
like how why are these people mad at us
like what happen what happens when when
when the jafa land in Paris and then a
musical breaks out you know I mean I
know a musical version with of Stargate
with ja dancing jafa is something that
Jamie is just been pounding the desk for
I think you pitched it to Bright didn't
didn't you pitch it to Brad Wright the
other day uh Jamie I to punch you in the
throat one of these days stormy honestly
I love you to death mate
but no
stop stop pitching
musicals but you know I think you know
whatever we do having going through
going forward whether it's in comic
books or whatever it does have to be
post-disclosure it does it just keeping
it secret for this
long at some point time there's gonna be
a bobazar that pops out of Area 51 or
whatever and loses the beans and it's
just going to be yeah YouTubers all over
getting in on yeah it has to be a post
disclosure story well they met times
they played with disclosure and
journalists and things in sg1 um you
know they did it three or four times um
teal being interviewed is still one of
my favorite scenes in in Star um but you
know I think if they go with something
that's still in the feel of the original
series I think they've got to um I mean
from from from what I've heard they that
they any new Creator will be allowed a
certain element of creative freedom but
they they it does should be a
continuation and that's what Amazon have
always said this is why Roland Emerick
isn't going to be doing a movie and he
quite publicly said they only care about
the TV
audience
um honestly this the best thing Roland
Em's ever
said um I love Roland Emer movies right
up until 2017 and then it's and I've not
loved him since Moon
moonfall I hate
moonfall visually
beautiful wonderfully
shot what's wonderfully shot oh
looks W and the effects were amazing but
yeah no logic all [__] um stop watching
Ancient Aliens Roland and and
yeah let's let's let's please we got
Stargate so I shouldn't really I
shouldn't really complain about that
because yes okay he he watched it
ancient alens got an idea for a series
um but anyway so let's just hope 2024
can be a merry a merry Christmas for for
Stargate basically absolutely I honestly
think it would have well we're 99%
certain it was supposed to be announced
at San Diego Comic-Con so yep
um if I mean from what I heard it was
2012 that's the movie I said 2017 like
four times didn't I 2012 the end of the
world that week
um yeah AB it's a stupid
movie um the end you get to the whole
with the aliens at the end it made even
less sense than the rest of the film it
just went off a DI anyway sorry I'll
start ranting about moonfall um so
Rebecca obviously working with a
companion for one I'd love to know how
did you first get involved in the
companion I meant to
ask uh yeah it's a good question
actually because of three fresh short I
was I was doing three fresh short with
Sarah and Christina first which that
came out of us finding all of all of our
community on Stargate uh Tik Tok so and
then uh people over there were like you
guys should be doing a podcast so we
started the podcast it's been almost
three years um and we I think I saw
uh Amanda Tapping tweet out that she was
doing a um elevating or wait no whatever
the the women in film and television uh
thing that she did with the companion
and I was like I want to watch that so I
I I joined I joined as a member first
and um and then like all the Stargate AI
started happening and I was like this is
really cool and then um we kind of my
podcast got interested in kind of taking
things further trying to do different
things and so so we set up a meeting
with Lawrence the founder of the
companion just to be like hey we'd
really like to like do some
collaboration stuff whatever and that
went on for a couple of months uh he
came on three fres short we talked with
him and everything and then um I I got a
message like two summers ago or whatever
from him he's like what do you think
about like joining the team and I was
like yes please um you know I went to
school for film but I was working in EMS
on an ambulance at the time so um yeah
it was it it was just like a great
opportunity so I was like let's do it um
and now I get to be a nerd full-time
which is awesome so
yeah that's my dream I only get days a
week um well I'm a nerd full-time
but I have prend I gota be paid to be a
nerd that's that's the that's the
awesome thing
yeah the
dream the dream that's how that happened
um and Lawrence uses a when he talks to
to people to Talent investors anybody he
uses my story a lot like oh Rebecca
works with us you was a member first
blah blah blah but it's true like I I
actually really liked what the companion
was doing before I before I was working
with them
so well we're a loyal um friend of the
companion which is why all the links are
in the description for the holiday
special really bad holiday special I
mean everything with Luke in it was just
awful yeah it's like he forgot how to
act see when you say holiday special I
don't think Star Wars I think Doctor
Who oh Michael bé starts singing in my
head as well which is actually very cool
I love that Michael bble holiday
specials
that's that's one of my highlights Carey
you know Christmas
special no no he dancing with as Santa
Claus dancing jafa Santas that's right
there we go in front of
dancing girls but with a J right
Christmas special okay all the El have
really small ones yeah bit 1970s holiday
special me but um but if you want yeah
um yeah in Britain it's the holiday
specials always like traditionally I I
don't know if you guys know [__] wise
and like some of those um sort of
comedians like that those are always the
holiday special they have the big song
production at the end but they haven't
done them in years and it's a
shame um don't really have them anymore
I think um we lost a bit of you know
like the healthy
cheesiness at Christmas sometimes which
which kind of miss it here we I think we
we're a bit
too serious sometimes well now some of
the biggest Christmas movies were things
like dark
Santa you know um I love the last year's
was it what was it called the one with
um oh his name's going out my head the
sheriff from oh Violet KN I watched
that yeah it was so good a sequ next
year I don't know how the sequel's going
to work but Violet night is the best
film it struck me as you know what
here's what I thought I was like
somebody watched the movie Scrooged and
then they went the night the reindeer
died we should just turn that into a
movie that's what I thought and then
they made violent night that's that's
how I see that happening I I said
exactly the same thing to my wife I said
at some point Lee Mages is going to pop
up in this film and she what are you
talking out what the night the reindeer
died the night the reindeer died yeah we
need to watch more movies
babe we've got to watch Scrooge you
should know but yeah I thought the same
thing it's yeah I was thought so went
die hard if it was actually a Christmas
movie a proper Christmas movie would be
this um it's like they got die hard and
um home alone and just
went all of the references I mean
because they're references to all of
like home like all of the movies in that
movie it's just really I enjoyed it way
more than I thought I would actually I
think I enjoyed it more than I should I
came go that's the best film ever
Oscars I will argue to to till the end
of of time that die hard is actually a
Christmas movie I was gonna say
currently have uh I currently have uh
Hans grber falling off of nakatomi
advent calendar like I get slide down a
day those are perfect those are
absolutely perfect I do have my jumper
is ho ho ho now I have a machine gun
written on it and we've got Christmas
jumper day next week at work no movie no
movie that has that many sleigh bells in
the score is not a Christmas movie like
it's everywhere in that score so just
say it exactly um it's it's a Christmas
um somebody said another film's a
Christmas movie because it's set it's
set roughly at Christmas it's like
aliens or something I can't remember
what it was now yeah there are a couple
of weird ones that make less sense as
Christmas movies yeah but set at
Christmas basically if Christmas is
mentioned it's a Christmas movie yeah um
go while we've got you then best
Christmas movies obviously vient
night any other favorites I was talking
to my wife about this today just to
thing what are you what are your
opinions on elf I'm not a huge elf
person I have friends who are like that
is their go-to Christmas movie I'm just
not I'm not I'm not big on it uh like I
said Scrooged I watched that one the
other day that one
that was it lethal
weapons thinking about thank you Sarah
you absolute Legend I'm
sorry yeah no Scrooged that is probably
one of my top ones to watch uh I watch
the Home Alone movies every Christmas I
love them um I was like Kevin's age when
that movie came out so it was super like
it was like the best thing ever to me um
I don't know die hard for sure I haven't
watched Die Hard yet this year I'm
saving it we waiting I watched it last
week I'm watching Die Hard 2 later nice
I've been going through some TV
Christmas episodes recently like going
back and watching some of my favorite
like I watched the X Files how the ghost
stle Christmas which is oh amazing yeah
I have to check that out that's it's
it's on Disney plus is that I have to
look that how
the Tomlin in it and um what Ed Asner
like that's amazing it's an amazing
episode I haven't watched X Files in
years like season three or season four
was that is that right I have to find
out they did two they did two Christmas
episodes but the better one is the one
where they're like stuck in the house
with the ghosts and they're the ghosts
are messing with them and Lily Tomlin is
just hilarious anyway like she's just an
amazingly hilarious person in general so
highly recommend I love the Christmas
episodes and shows like that any of the
shows that ran that that season sort of
thing always had a Christmas show like
like a lot the cop shows and things you
know like um castle with Nathan
Philly I literally watched it about a
week ago and Santa Claus just falls from
a I think it's an airplane he falls from
he just Falls and no can figure out did
he fall from a
sleigh Castle SP the whole episode going
he's real I love it yeah but so yeah I
love those sorts of things and we again
we don't really have them in we what
we'll have is it is there'll be a
Christmas Standalone episode in in this
country so there'll be like whatever the
sitcom is that's on they'll have a
Christmas special
they don't even do that anymore as much
as they used to at least at least Doctor
Who's still doing things for it for
getting a Christmas special a proper one
yeah first time in in a few years um you
could tell when Doctor Who's popularity
started to weigh they immediately it
went from Christmas Day for a few for
five or six years it was the thing
everyone everyone like sit and watch the
queen and then watch Doctor Who special
that was what everyone did Christmas day
um and then it got pushed to New Year's
Eve and then they stopped doing it yeah
you could see it was
like and which was a shame but yeah I I
don't know if there's any big Christmas
movies I've just watched Wonka by the
way it's amazing is it so good is this
the prequel yeah it's beautiful honestly
it's a it's a proper prequel to Gan
Wilder's version wow I was worried about
that it'd be like some sort of [__] what
they did was they got the Johnny Depp
version and they took it outside shot it
and then set fire to
it then did Jean Wilder a prequel to Gan
Wilder's version there's loads of little
nods the lad from June is marvelous he's
so good um the songs are actually good
for a musical they're brilliant see I do
like musicals see it's just the Star
Trek musical I hate but I do like
musicals sometimes um but um I don't
hate the Star Trek musical um but yeah
oh that was going to remind me about my
one of my favorite Christmas movies is
the Muppet Christmas Carol oh that's a
good
one I need to watch that this year
that's a solid one yeah yeah that's
lovely I I was talking to my wife about
this earlier though I don't like elf elf
is is not a very good film with three or
four brilliant bits
in it's not it's not a very good film um
so no I'm like like Scrooge hav in a
wonderful life I watch a wonderful life
every year with my mom um and um and she
gets drunk and then starts
if this was real
oh love you my my extended family is
really big on um Christmas vacation as a
Christmas
movie they all watch that I kind of I
got sick of it because we had you know
the whole family watched it so many
times so um but maybe I'll watch it
again this year maybe it's been long
enough since I watched it I don't know
yeah you gota watch G I watched it for
the first time in years last year
actually and it is better than I
remember yeah it's one of those films
because I think the the Lampoon movies
got a bit silly so I think it like
tainted the good ones a little bit in my
mind s thing yeah vacation and Christmas
Vacation are the the two for me you know
like those are the those are the the the
you know standards basically at this
point but um yeah vacation a couple
years ago with Christine Applegate and
it's actually really
good like remake it brilliant really
good film um but before I said I I
promised we'd stay to about an hour and
already been waffling on for 40 minutes
yeah no kidding um so I'd love to talk
to you about a couple of the interviews
you've done Rebecca I think I mean
because I mean a couple of the ones with
Manda tapping are the ones I've watched
because I work in mental health that's
my job and while I work in Social care
now um but um so obviously I took a keen
interest in in in watching those and and
um particularly through Co and things
people's mental health of the entire
nation took a no dive yeah um but what
what are the what I
mean I got massively over excited just
talk to Brad Wright for 15 minutes yeah
a few weeks ago um what sort of
interviews what are the ones are the
highlights you can think of or oh aand
is definitely the Highlight uh
definitely the
it's it's it's like producing producing
and hosting an event with Amanda Tapping
if like you would ask me two years ago
if I was going to do that in 2023 if
that was on my 2023 bingo card I would
have been like what are you talking
about no never um and then to be able to
do it and then to to be able to not only
produce and and like interview her but
actually do an event that feels really
meaningful and and good and that was the
other part of it because I also like I
said I worked in EMS before I worked at
the companion so I worked EMS all
through three years of covid that we you
know until I stopped um and the mental
health struggles just just as much as
the physical um Health stuff was just it
was just it was just insane to to see
everybody just kind of spiraling during
that time so it was really she she had
mentioned to the companion over a year
ago that she wanted to do something
around mental health so I'm glad we
could finally get it going and it's just
I mean I I I did not even try to hide
the fact that I have like the picture
with her from a convention like 13 years
ago on my desk um I'm is like I'm just
owning it at this point um but know it's
just that that those two almost three
we're going to do another one in January
and then she came on three fres short
too we talked all about DIY stuff around
the house it was still um still during
the strike and so we were like we won't
talk about that Wormhole show that's
what we were calling it during the
strike
um no shade to like podcast that kept
talking about struck work during the
strike but as a filmmaker who's trying
to get my first feature film like out
the door I didn't want to ruffle any
feathers so and fortunately Sarah and
Christina were very you know supportive
of that so we just started watching
documentaries that weren't produced by
um struck companies and just talked
about that instead but the DIY stuff was
was was really fun like just how do you
not go and make any MacGyver comments if
if Mand is starting talking about doing
a de so putting a shelf
up how did my guy for that then you'd
have to I mean I would I would have said
it about 90 times in three minutes yeah
I I don't know I I don't I Fort I think
fortunately that we didn't think about
it basically but um being British I got
a lower form of
wit that came to my mind uh yeah but no
she show she showed us like a a what
fires cider recipe that like you can you
know if you're feeling sick or whatever
it's good for your immune system
apparently she showed Noti like
wallpaper in her bathroom that she had
done and stuff so it was just a it was
just Next Level it just felt like you
know four ladies sitting around a table
talking and that was so so wonderful and
so cool and she is just so gracious so
amazing um so willing to not so for the
mental health things we we did the live
stream and then we did we would did
these Green Room sessions afterwards so
we did 15 minute sessions that four
people at a time and so she ended up SP
in you know three
hours talking about mental health and
stuff and that's like that's that's a
lot that's heavy to like to sit in it
for three hours um and she just she she
was a champ like amazing with it so that
was that's probably the the biggest
highlight but I have a soft spot in my
heart um for Sue and braa because suanne
was the first Stargate person I
interviewed ever on three fres short and
we love her to death
so that was kind of because she was our
first we we still we still love her too
um and she's a wonderful guest as well
she's very interesting you get her
talking about theater stuff um you know
she's been doing a lot of musical like
type theater things recently
so yeah and Brad I mean of course Brad
right I don't know i' I
actually yeah I the the one that the one
that's a little different that wasn't
virtual is I got to fly out last
November not this November the November
before and film in person a round table
with Chris judge um and so I actually
got to like film him and and direct him
in person which that was pretty wild you
have to like throw him a few valum or
something to try to get him to calm down
for 30 bloody seconds so that he could
concentrate that man has more energy
than a Stargate he was great he did
great well so the topic of that one was
we called it elevating black voices in
sci-fi and was a round table with him
and all these other black creators of
different in different you know
podcasters we had somebody that works on
the cruise everybody talking about again
really heavy topic of you know but he
was into it and he wanted to do it um so
I think that's he he he was so good in
that interview because it was kind of
his baby I think and I think he still
wants to do more of those he wants to
have more tables discussions um but that
was right before he won uh what the game
award for
uh still going on now he's still up
there still going on yeah you know died
three months ago and he's still um still
talking uh did you see his and his
because he obviously he was there again
was it last night or the night before
yeah yeah the Call of Duty
slam of dut my speech was longer than
Call of Duty
campaign I just love him I he's
um you know because I being obsessive
about star you always watch the um
outtakes and things and I swear to God
it's always Christopher Judge that
causes the problem it'll be every single
time it's him that starts giggling
that's and then Amanda will start
giggling yeah and then it's over yeah um
we did we covered Ergo on three friyay
short not too long ago we did it right
before the strike started so it took a
while and then we finally released it
but um it was cool like in the chevron's
locked book that the oral history you
know the unauthorized history um there's
the story in there that the real the
reason um Chris judge like Tik isn't in
much of that episode is because he
couldn't hold it together long enough
around Don deloise like he kept laughing
so they just had to cut his part down
drastically so yeah every time Dom d
said
anything Christ just burst laughing yeah
um I saw one of the interviews they did
at the when it sort of done and I think
they sat around a table at a bar or
something and and Christopher Judge just
walks in and it's just like the energy
level is just go it's just he's a force
of nature as much as anything else I
don't he showed up to that interview in
these like golf pants that had like
really bright colored hearts all over
them it's just like what is happening
right now this is wild it was a fever
dream like flying out to LA 48 Hours
shoot the thing fly back home it was it
was wild but it was great it was uh you
know that that was definitely another
highlight just because it was in person
it was really nice to to like meet in
person so I think if ever I got the
opportunity I'd love to talk to Chris
judge but um David huet as well is one
that I I do think if ever if ever we can
convince David hit stormy you you could
geek out with that man did I think it'd
be dangerous I any if anybody here
watched the Legacy event that we did
last weekend it was Brad Rob Cooper and
David huet about uh Rising it was
supposed to be about Rising Parts one
and two and then 45 minutes into the
live stream they were just still talking
like about
whatever they they I mean they just kept
going it was great it was wonderful but
um yeah I just knew I knew Lawrence and
Tommy had like their whole outline and I
I messaged them on Discord halfway
through and I was like rip that outline
you know because it was
just but they just they just got
together and I think they um they hadn't
talked like that in so long it was just
friends catching up Rob Cooper was
amazing in that he just the stories he
just kept coming out with and Brad was
like I forgot about
that I I just I was just kep watching
Tommy's face because all the way through
he's just like didn't say a word he's
just
like like like what like all of us
audience watching just like Tommy you
are involved me supposed to say they
couldn't get they couldn't get a word in
they could not get a word in it was
great like you could La Lawrence tried a
couple of times I think Tommy tried once
and it was just like nope they're just
going to keep going it's great yeah um
yeah Lawrence did try once or twice to
steer it back
didn't forget it forget it um but yeah I
I just think David huet is one of those
actors that um you'd want to sit and
have a drink with and just go
go sit back and enjoy it something for
sure he's such a passionate guy but um
stormmy actually does he's an engineer
and he builds spaceships for a living so
I'm just I'm just going to aim stormy at
him
perfect I would yeah aim aim stor at him
and then just film it you're you're good
to go yeah sit back and watch um but
like said yeah it's it's been so just
again before we we say goodbye to you I
Rebecca and thank you so much for coming
on by the way it's been brilliant and
I'd love talk to you guys absolutely
next week oh oh Tommy's on tomorrow by
the way I'm yeah I know I know we talked
about uh that we were like double double
teaming it this we it might become us
talking about Manchester United for two
he said that too he said that too yeah
yeah we had a bad day oh really bad day
bring Tommy and have a good chat about
it then yeah and we lost man united lost
seven nil to Liverpool once at our
trials during a live stream and I still
get comments because I kept looking at
my phone throughout it and at 40 I threw
my phone down didn't talk and I still
get comments on turn the notifications
off during the stream because it's G to
go badly but yeah so um I've already had
like four comments off him
but nice that's so we got he's coming on
tomorrow but just tell us again before
we head off what the companion doing at
Christmas you can tease us a little bit
of anything that's plan i''d be amazing
and just remind everybody there's links
in the description yeah so next weekend
next Saturday the 16th come on over to
the companions YouTube
uh YouTube channel uh you don't have to
sign up for anything usually we have
member exclusive streams but this one is
completely open too um just like our
celebration was when we did the simoc
cast which we're hopefully going to do
another one of those before too long as
well um but come hang out uh we're we're
gonna show some talk about some of our
events that we have had over the past
year and you know just what all has
happened we're gonna have a couple of
holiday specific segments including
things like all these decorations that
people have found there like Stargate
holiday
decorations um we I like I said there
will be some beverage recipes coming out
so you can make your own drink to to
drink along but uh I will be trying them
live so we'll see we'll see how how they
taste um and we have
a yeah we we have the the gate before
Christmas which uh you can just sorry my
dogs are are picking right now to Wine
um the gate Before Christmas is a
Stargate version of the Night Before
Christmas and uh yes uh it it is
happening it's going to happen so you
have to come to hear it because I'm
pretty proud of the way it turned out um
yeah that's it um yeah come come it's
free we will be in the in the chat I
will be bothering you in the in the
conversation don't
worry oh yeah Brad's gonna be there too
so everybody that wasn't here at the
beginning Brad Wright is gonna be
hanging out with us I think it's gonna
be me Lawrence Brad maybe I can do a
little like fireplace little box too
like we're sit around the fireplace or
something
um trying to recreate that you know
virtually was kind of difficult but I'm
going to Basin Stoke ComicCon uh in May
I will I will see you there then
excellent oh that's amazing um I have
already told Brad I he ain't getting out
of that building without me there is
absolutely no chance because I'm sorry I
know that there will be an element of
stalking um I'm having pictures with RDA
and Joe
Flanigan he hadn't announced at that
point um so but so Brad I'm not paying
for another picture mate he was I think
it was one of the one of the live
streams we did with him like beforehand
or in a tech check or something he's
like oh they're trying to get me to go
to basing Stoke with that like Rick is
and we we're all like well I mean we're
all going to be there like you should
just go like so yeah he was he was a
late edition but it's G to be really
cool I know there's no way I'm missing
that because it's Brad Rick Amanda and a
whole bunch of other people I'm flying
over to that one I think the fries are
gonna come with me we're trying I'm
trying to get all the fries over there
so um it'll be nice to meet everybody in
person well me and Matt will come and
find you and we'll say hello that be
amazing um I'm trying to find out if I
can film from there but I'm trying to
get in touch with the people that run it
but we'll see yeah so yeah the people
that run it well the one in particular
that runs it yeah it it'll get better in
January she said basically so try try to
talk in January so yeah I've had a word
with Tommy about it he says yeah just
give her give her a chance and it'll
come back so well think it would be
amazing really looking forward to um I'm
going be there on the Sunday so BR like
where can I go play golf and and I was
like I actually know there's I know a
golf course just because but it's but
the um the 18 you know the um the bar is
awful he like I'll be
fine he might just disappear he might
just disappear oh yeah probably anyway
thank you so so
much thanks for having me on it was
great we really appreciate you coming on
we really do yeah
and um and we'll have you again and like
I say we'll see Tommy tomorrow on our
regular live video and yeah just tell
them I say hi I'll see him on Monday I
will I I don't if he's stopped crying by
then if I'm honest oh my gosh yeah
should I should I send him like a
thinking of view card or
something yeah sympy card a Pity card is
always appropriate yeah yeah yeah the
only problem is if you start that you're
setting a precedent and the way man
united are playing at the moment you're
going to have to do it like twice a week
so um you gotta make the commitment
there bro you gotta make you gota be
willing to make the commitment yeah it's
All or Nothing All or Nothing
so we had 20 years on top it's our own
fault anyway yeah it is actually your
person but yeah no no I sometimes it
feels
personal stormy thank you this is my
microphone I if you can get it I mean
I've got a real microphone is this not
is this not working is you just kind of
got to get closer to it because you can
hear all the you can hear your whole
room too like the Reverb
hello there you go little bit chilling
in the basement we through it we push
through it guys I've said it thank you
so so much uh happy holidays to both of
you I'm see you tomorrow so I don't know
why I've said that um and yeah byebye
everybody bye
toodles
[Music]